we will halve inflation this year to
ease the cost of living and give people
Financial Security that was UK prime
minister Rishi sunak at the beginning of
the year pledging to cut inflation in
half which at that time was 10.5 percent
inflation has since Fallen to 8.7
percent which is good but experts and
officials are more interested in
something else core inflation which has
actually risen since the start of the
Year what's behind that rise and what
does it mean for Rishi sunak's big
pledge
first it's important to understand the
difference between core inflation and
headline inflation headline inflation is
the classic Benchmark for Consumer
prices it calculates an index based on
stuff that we buy like food energy rent
clothes and a whole bunch of other stuff
core inflation strips out the more
volatile things like food and energy and
this is the metric that the bank of
England is closely watching right now UK
headline inflation is falling but at a
slur Pace in other major economies it's
still twice as high as in the US the
UK's core inflation meanwhile is
traveling in the opposite direction it's
now at its highest level since 1992
fueled by higher wages and corporate
profits one of the big drivers of this
is services so that's prices for things
like air travel cultural Goods other
kinds of services this is in contrast
with the US and the Eurozone where core
inflation has been coming down recently
in the US one of the big reasons for
this was the cooling of housing rental
prices
persistently High Core inflation could
make the prime minister's goal harder to
achieve the treasury Chief says the
target of around five percent inflation
is still possible but it won't be easy I
think the sweet spot for the UK economy
in terms of our long-term
competitiveness is if we can do the best
of what European countries do in terms
of investment in skills investment in
infrastructure but have that
U.S dynamism Innovation spark Hunt's
desired Sweet Spot Will in part depend
on if that core inflation rate can start
to follow the U.S and Eurozone in a
downward Direction
the government is supported in its
efforts by the bank of England the
Central Bank sees raising interest rates
as its best tool to bring inflation down
to its own two percent Target it has
been raising the rate since the end of
2021.
this makes borrowing more expensive
which leads to people having less money
to spend which lowers Demand on goods
and ultimately slows prices central
banks have had a really difficult job
recently they've been trying to tame
inflation with interest rates being
their main tool but they also have to
try to raise interest rates without
damaging the economy too severely so
it's about finding this delicate
Balancing Act in the US we've seen the
FED pause interest rates while it's
assessing the impact of this latest
hikes but it does look like in the UK
because of this persistently High
inflation the Boe is unlikely to be able
to uh posits hiking cycle anytime soon
foreign foreign